no no no no no no no no no no Beccati
questo robo metti 9000 Benvenuti su
Anita Stories Eccoci qua finalmente sono
un nuovissimo gioco bellissimo il nuovo
gioco che è uscito e dovremo sconfiggere
affrontare la nuova maestra cattiva però
questa maestra che si chiama Betty poi
come sempre avete capito i Popcorn
lasciate un bel mi piace e iniziamo
subito la sfida Ciao ciao Allora facile
o difficile e facciamo facile perché
siamo un po' Skipper e questo è un gioco
in prima persona altro che a voi
piacciono un sacco i giochi in prima
persona Cosa vuol dire gioco a prima
persona che noi abbiamo la visuale come
se fossimo veramente lì quel personaggio
quindi non vediamo il personaggio da
fuori vediamo con i suoi Oh io vedo Rita
per esempio Ehi Anita ciao Eccoti
Guardate che cosa Vitale in testa
Ovviamente un piatto con i dolci
schiacciamo in testa perché non può
resistere neanche nei giochi Allora dove
siamo siamo in una specie di scuola
f e che facciamo Se facciamo F
diventiamo noi il professor il proprio
la professoressa
professoressa
[Musica]
voglio essere Anita Ok proviamo a
scappare faccio la classifica Qua c'è un
pulsante ovviamente sembra di prendere
il pulsante rosso Raccontaci
[Musica]
può essere che sentirà l'odore del cibo
nella tua testa Francesco
sta guardando fuori dalla finestra non
si è accorta di niente per ora io sto
seguendo te Sì sono io in quel quadretto
là No
sono bravissimo ho preso una piú tu vedi
te stesso amore Io vedo me Vabbè basta
c'è qualcosa qui
Nel passaggio allora aspetta io provo ad
aprire questa porta OK
[Musica]
Chiusa Ah lei al telefono
Ecco perché non si è accorta di noi
niente
No sono nella sua testa ah ah ah ah È
troppo distante al telefono Dobbiamo
fare quello che vogliamo Beccati questo
bene Ora è stato facile questo stage non
si è accorta di niente io e ora vediamo
cosa ci aspetta i labirinti Io odio
labirinto Dai faccio io da Guido
Beh bisogna prenderlo a calci Ah ok
dobbiamo buttarci giù
E comunque volevo dire che io ancora non
mi sono sfracellato eh Vedremo vedremo
quanto durerà questa cosa che non ti
devi dispiacere
qualcuno si è buttato giù Poverino
Vediamo cosa succede Oh Che figo
Ho capito adesso Capito Non ti azzardare
Ehi aspetta Eccolo no
qualcuno sta stragelato Hahaha Ehi ma è
difficilissimo
in prima persona è più difficile so che
tutto anch'io come non detto Sì scrivete
nei commenti Preferite i giochi in prima
persona o in terza persona cioè che
vedete il personaggio Secondo me sono
più belli e tu quali preferisci invece
su immersivi sembra di essere veramente
libero
schiappa Ecco perché adesso ce l'hai
fatta Ah Ok andiamo avanti
tanto qui Dobbiamo saltare Ciao
ciao Dov'è finito ma siamo a scuola di
nuovo ancora parlato
ci stai seguendo aiuto aiuto aiuto Mi
stai seguendo Aiuto Aiuto dove devo
andare Dove posso prendere
No qua c'è la porta non mi fa così No
che brutta sorpresa mi ha preso anche a
me riproviamo ok Quindi bisogna premere
il bottone scappando dalla maestra e poi
andando alla porta perché si apre la
porta
non succede come devi cliccare qui no
no no no no no no no no no Io ho ripreso
Ma come si fa non si può fare corriamo
il più veloce possibile e non guardare
dietro di te perché sennò la vedi e ti
fa paura eh E non riesce a scappare Ehi
no aspetta un momento ma io ho provato a
buttare ma non è successo niente
tu praticamente devi schivarla quindi
apre la porta e poi devo tornare
indietro
e però
molto Allora ho provato Ah no
Ehi lasciate un mi piace per portarmi
fortuna
non avete lasciato mi piace davvero
perché non mi ha portato fortuna ancora
qui dentro mi raccomando cliccate mi
piace farli giocare così riesco a
scappare dal Betty la maestra cattiva
allora adesso vai è tutto dritto vai
dritto verso i cubi entra di qua poi
quando premi il bottone giri di qua e
vai subito qua dietro Ok ci provo Vai
vai Brava brava vai così vai Prendi il
potere
tutto tutto dritto Ma guarda lì dov'è
Dov'è dov'è Dov'è dov'è Dov'è questo ce
l'ho fatta prova Anita ecco
ti non premere il pulsante non prendere
il pulsante Allora dici Certo Costruisci
la tua strada Wow
bellissimo stavo costruendo la strada Se
non si era capito
Ehi guarda è successo qualcosa c'è un
bagno
tremando Ah ah ah ah ho capito Bisogna
bisogna mettere in cubi qua sopra per
salire su sì perfetto
Ok dai Questo è facile finché non ce la
maestra è facilissimo Togliti devo
passare prima io non rovinare la mia
costruzione No ciao ciao Non rovinare la
costruzione Aspetta che ti faccia cadere
dall'altra parte no
adesso ti tolgo via tutti i blocchi e io
ti prendo cibo latte Sei già passata non
mi dicono che forza Adesso ci provo eh
sono tutti un po' traballanti no li ho
messi troppo lontani Uh no non riesco a
salire un po' Forse sì Vediamo Ah ah ah
ah
Prendere il badge prima di prendere
Apriti apriti butta giù questa grata
non so come facciamo uscire da qua Ah da
qua sopra Sì ho capito bisogna andare
qua Dai Seguimi sono qua sono caduto
devo rifare tutto da capo adesso Vitale
e per colpa del tuo vassoio di dolci in
testa non riuscire a metterti
l'equilibrio poteva essere prima di
mangiare Ecco perché adesso faccio una
piccola pausa mi mangio tutto questo
passaggio di negozi il prima possibile
Oh troppo forte Ti ho raggiunto dove sei
veramente sono ancora io in testa
Cosa sono i laser sì Ehi Aspetta ma
siamo in trappola Ah no si continua qua
mi ero accorto
strano che non mi sono sfracellata nei
laser in genere mi sfracello
[Musica]
qua c'è un'altra persona guarda
sarà il fidanzato della maestra
professore
la musica Ah Bisogna bisogna eliminare
aiuto aiuto aiuto è arrabbiatissimo è
arrabbiatissimo custode Ah ecco bisogna
sparare
subito
tu sono
[Musica]
esploso tipo era fatto di di quella
sostanza verde pubblico prima nella
fogna quindi quindi
questo video Beccati questo oh oh oh
no veramente tu hai il fucile invisibile
io quello vero papà Ok andiamo Oh che
dici Metti le lettere corrette su una
bacheca
amicissimo eccola qui potevate farlo un
po' più difficili
dovevate farlo più difficile tipo con le
equazioni di matematica
Ok la C Ok ok
Eccola qua e adesso si è aperta la porta
corri corri corri vengo anch'io dobbiamo
salire qua sopra eh È facilissimo guarda
dove dobbiamo andare
aiuto
Avete visto come si è sfracellato in
Italia
[Musica]
vediamo dobbiamo elaborare una strategia
sono riuscito a passare
Sei riuscito a scappare
scappa sulla scale continua a scappare
continua a scappare Anita
[Applauso]
[Musica]
No l'ha presa Vai corri corri corri
salta salta salta Ok ce l'ho fatta
Sì bruttissimo non posso lanciargli
qualcosa vorrei lanciare qualcosa in
testa
scappiamo presto
Siamo tornati a scuola e no aspetta
siamo ritornati tutti
siamo tornati dove eravamo prima dove
dobbiamo andare adesso non dovevamo
saltare lì ho capito cosa dovevo fare
una volta saliti là sopra Dobbiamo
camminare sui tubi
Eh sì Adesso ti faccio vedere Fai come
prima Fai come prima corri corri corri
Ok ce l'hai fatta allora Ah ho capito
No no se cadiamo giù tornerà Betty a
prenderci e tu infatti sei caduto No ho
preso come ha fatto a prenderti da qua e
ancora hai preso da sotto dai dai Vitale
facciamo tutto il tifo per te corri con
il tuo piattino tu scemo intanto mi dai
anche equilibrista perché riesci a non
far cadere niente da adesso piatto
intanto dici si tratta di cibo Guarda
sono passato Ok Dove siamo venite
[Musica]
ci provo Oh Oh Oh
bravissimo Saipem quasi fatta
L'equilibrista Vitale capiamo più
velocemente
Ehi ma dove siamo adesso cosa c'entra
questo posto con la scuola sotto la
scuola c'era tutto questa struttura
gigantesca coi cubi che fluttuano
tanto A cosa serve da evitare facciamo
il tifo per te ma nel frattempo ti
supero Wow che bello volare
[Musica]
salti sulla prima ventola che ti fa
saltare in aria con l'aria che è venuto
salti sulla seconda poi alla seconda eh
per non scorreggia
questo è il tuo trucco per passare il
disegno il Jetpack scorreggia devi usare
Ok ce l'ho fatta anche senza scoreggia
con papà
no via via via via voglio tornare a
scuola
Prendi prendi invece carità indietro
cosa il badge Ah ah ah
Sono in supervantaggio Ciao Anita Ciao
Sì ciao ciao
[Musica]
aiuto
labirinto mi sto perdendo questa
labirinto Dov'è usa le assi di metallo
di metallo per attraversarlo Io sono un
trucchetto
fai il trucchetto No nessuno scherzetto
[Musica]
sono scomparse no Ma cosa allora
scompaiono solo per me sì lo so anch'io
il trucchetto che era bellissimo
tornare indietro e prendere tutte le
assi così non bisogna
tornare indietro
non Dovevo metterla qua eh Ciao ciao
anche a tornare indietro No
ecco perché bisognava tornare indietro
bisogna prendere almeno due volte il
trucchetto ora vi devo completare tutto
e adesso pure io non ha funzionato
questa volta ma questa volta funzionerà
perché devo stare attenta a non cadere
Allora
latte riprendiamola
e quindi devo andare qua
ho capito attenta che ce ne avevo anche
un altro io il primo sono riuscito a
farlo però nel secondo sono caduto nel
tranello Ma io non cadrò perché bisogna
mettere l'acqua vero
Sono davanti sono prima questo non è per
niente giusto Comunque te lo volevo dire
Eh perché no perché mi hai sorpassato e
non sai perdere
lo sapevo lo sapevo guardate guarda
questo è difficilissimo
che cosa
lato sono in avanti invece no sono
sfrinella
ce l'ho fatta No no ce l'ho fatta No la
risposta era no no no Io stranamente ce
l'ho fatta dai puoi farcela anche tutto
ce l'ho fatta io come ce l'hai fatta
scusa
A proposito
Ah che Vitale è riuscito a passare col
Fridge Ma io sono comunque più avanti di
te eh Figo cioccolato mi piacciono
troppo questi stage qui con le con le
ventole sotto che ti fanno volare
su Wow siamo tornati a scuola
[Musica]
e qua bisogna prendere qualcosa da bere
eh un biberon Beh beh ma in che senso
scusa Anzi siamo troppo grandi per bene
[Musica]
il biberon super velocità Sì
no non è vero
devi cliccare una volta che lo selezioni
con il numero uno
devi cliccare poi una volta che abbiamo
avuto il numero deve cliccare adesso via
mi sono sfaccellato ora
super velocità Allora io dico che È
strabello Ma io non ti vedo dove sei
perché mi sono sfracellato ho dovuto
ricominciare da capo arrivo super
velocità Dai sbrigati
[Musica]
Betty è diventata un robot C'è una
ragazza strana dobbiamo fare adesso
dobbiamo sparare dappertutto pulitore
Che brutta Che cosa mangia biscotti uh
uh
balletto no attenzione perché ogni tanto
fa quella Honda energetica viola anche
il balletto uh uh uh uh
anche questo Beh non è troppo difficile
però eh Siamo nel cortile della scuola
hai visto mi sta sfruttando uh
ti sei riuscito
Anita No sono morta devo rifare tutto da
capo tra l'altro
carinissima Preferisci
una cosa troppo allontana tira un
pochettino
No aiuto ha lanciato l'onda energetica
Dai dai dai
quattro panini Ancora no ho fatto guarda
guarda guarda guarda
Wow un Bigfoot rosa ah ah la macchina
gigante rossa Che bella la vorrei
davvero ho preso il peggio ho preso il
peggio
l'ho preso il peggio Hahaha
cosa stiamo andando
ma ma no io volevo guidare
siamo tornati a scuola
Esatto L'Italia non è scappato questo
cesso Ecco questi vediamo mi metti Non
lo so vediamo
dopo grazie grazie
completamente
[Applauso]
per vedere i nostri video cliccate su
quella che preferite Ecco ciao